welcome back to the show now one of the
most unexpected rap battles in history
is underway on the left perhaps in more
ways than one that's Eminem on the right
you get the idea that's high-flying
presidential hopeful Vivek Rama Swami
this unlikeliest of spats began when
Vivek went viral for rapping to Eminem's
Lose Yourself at the Iowa State Fair
everybody's joking now the clocks run
out time's up over plow snap back to
reality off the goes gravity oh there
goes gravity Joe he's so mad but he
won't give up that easy now Eminem's
lawyers after that issued an immediate
cease and desist letter Banning Rama
Swami from ever doing it again at least
in public so was Eminem right to protect
Integrity of his work in this Urban
genre from appropriation by a wealthy
politician or has he lost himself to
debate all of it I'm joined by Los
Angeles America's number one Eminem
impersonator on YouTube Vincent Marcus
Maga rapper Forgiato blow he is in
Florida for us and outkick host Tommy
Lara and friend of the show joining us
from Nashville as ever
um I will come to you first Forgiato uh
is the performance worth it was Vivek
doing any good
I get my 8 out of 10.
um I think Eminem needs to go back to
reality though The Real Slim Shady needs
to stand up you know he made his whole
career on bashing White America picking
on people to get on he is the face of
hate speech when hate speech even
started I don't see any problem with
that doing the song I mean does he have
a problem with the man of color playing
his music no one Detroit's ever played
his music he seems like he thinks his
music is for drug dealers and drug users
a white America bought his music so
there shouldn't be an issue it's freedom
of speech I feel Vincent you're the
number one Eminem impersonator what did
you make in a performance
uh I thought it was great uh nine out of
ten because he really had the you know
that too but he had the like the Eminem
boost honk like that huh perfect perfect
inflection on there so uh I really
really nice job there
um yeah I think he did great so why did
Eminem not like it then
I think that's obviously politically
motivated I think because he was so
anti-trump vocally very vocally so much
in fact the Secret Service came to him
and questioned him about his lyrics and
the validity of them and so I think he
just wants to stay out of politics and
he's like uh maybe not you know I'm out
I think he I think he learned his lesson
on that for a little bit well let's
remind ourselves of the number of
musicians that have banned Donald Trump
a certain former president from playing
their music at his events Adele
Aerosmith The Beatles Bruce Springsteen
Eddie Grant Elton John I mean I go
Pavarotti Nickelback Pharaoh Williams
Phil Collins prince Queen REM I mean it
goes on and on and on Tommy what's all
this about
oh I think it's obviously politically
motivated and I'm sure Eminem Slim Shady
doesn't want a republican candidate
singing to his song but the real winner
here is actually Vivek because although
he might have gotten that cease and
desist letter it really doesn't matter
because we're talking about it and
that's what Vivek wants he wants to
create some kind of a controversy he
wants to get earned media air time and
this story has continued to progress so
by Eminem's company Slim Shady by them
sending the seasoned assist letter
they've just really helped Vivek out get
him more air time get more press about
the issue and it's also cemented his
Underdog status right which people love
yeah I mean you've got a point Tommy
we're talking about it right now here on
a show from the UK it's got our
attention that much Forgiato coming to
you I mean Rama Swami he's had a life of
some privilege compared to Eminem he
went to Yale and Harvard Forbes says
he's worth 950 million dollars is it
cultural appropriation
I don't think it is because with Eminem
be where he was at if he didn't have
G-Unit or in 50 Cent walking him in and
Dr Dre getting them where he was going I
mean Eminem yeah he probably had to
struggle just like everybody here it
wasn't easy for you to get your job but
you know I think vivec's doing a good
job like we're saying he's getting his
name out there obviously I'm voting
Trump but I like that I think he's doing
a good job on the campaign trails and
you know he did say he'll pardon Trump
so I like that okay Vincent uh in terms
of just politicians trying to seem cool
using rap music to try and get attention
like Tommy was saying is it at all worth
it do you think it helps them in the
polls
I think so I mean if I I really enjoyed
the performance and I think that it
definitely did help or it will because
again like the time you said we're
talking about it so again I think it uh
I think it's a nice tool for politicians
to use to sort of gain some traction
um but yeah I think uh I I don't say
again I don't see anything wrong with
what he did but again if you get a
season just List season desist later
from Eminem
that's pretty gangster that's cool like
that's cool in itself so like Eminem the
biggest gangster of all time was just
like you know what
maybe you want to pull back a little bit
but maybe maybe pull back so that's just
that's cool in itself Vincent have you
ever met Eminem has you ever sent you a
cease deceased letter no if I got one
from him I would say oh my gosh I exist
I would love that but no uh no he is not
reached out I have not met him yet I
would love to
um but no not yet okay all right well
maybe he'll watch this and maybe he'll
get in touch with you and tell you what
it makes if you're impersonations look
Tommy
politicians uh kind of trying to seem
cool let's look at this latest clip
we've got of a certain Ted Cruz
they're trying to go after and regulate
ceiling fans I got to tell you it's hot
in Texas we don't want to get rid of our
ceiling fans and now these idiots have
come out and said drink two beers a week
that's their guideline well I got to
tell you if they want us to drink two
beers a week frankly they can kiss my
ass
no okay
um
left the news anchor there pretty pretty
speechless Tommy that is Ted Cruz
getting some chaps some cowboys behind
into a crack open a brewski at the same
time and to prove what a down to earth
guy he is does this kind of stick work
I think it actually is pretty authentic
to Ted Cruz to speak that way I mean
he's a Texan so I think that it
resonates and as long as he's not
drinking Bud Light I think that the
Republican party is going to be okay
with it as we know with the Bud Light
controversy so that's a sore spot for
conservatives being that the Bud Light
boycott is still ongoing but I'll say
this it really depends on your audience
right so he's a Texan that's the way
Texans talk the vague he's a young guy
rapping although when when they try to
play up to this hip cool attitude around
an audience of like Iowa State Fair
goers I'm not sure that it really
resonates with that audience but I think
it's all about just being authentic you
know if we've got Chris Christie up
there rapping 50 Cent I'm not sure that
that's going to do well for him so it
depends on the time the place and the
person if you've got a natural swag you
can do it let's not forget that Donald
Trump over the years has been in dozens
of rap songs so he's actually the OG of
this before they hated him they love to
rap about him well how about Trump
rapping this latest clip that has
appeared on line an AI developed Trump
rap track that's topping the charts
homies doing life in jail they live in
it now these days acting silly my
mugshot is with the Billy sells the
merchant made a militia
baby
butcher then my rollers called me racist
but these rappers riding with me they're
my soldiers
is that is that any good in your mind
yeah I think it was great it's great for
the culture any song that shouts out
Danny Johnson I love it um I was outside
the jailhouse and a lot of people
weren't really showing the support you
know Donald Trump's getting from the
brown and black community they were out
there so I think it was really cool you
know there's a lot of people like myself
out here doing a lot of things so shout
out high res I'm glad he got that spot I
hope he gets that number one spot for
Donald Trump and just uh quickly though
I mean there's a lot of lyrics in there
that obviously Trump hasn't said himself
but AI has created about shooting people
I mean is that gonna help his campaign
I didn't hear anything in there about
shooting anybody so I didn't hear that
but I think it just you know sometimes
people just gotta laugh and have fun
right everything's so serious people
weren't worried about Eminem when he was
talking about Robin killing and shooting
every gay person in America now they're
supporting him so you know I just think
that was great I like the song Eminem
not running for president though
obviously Trump didn't create that song
himself it's AI generated maybe I
misheard the shooting thing I'll take it
back and listen again but one thing we
do want to listen to again and this is
with Vincent in mind very carefully
let's once again listen to Vivek
ramaswamy rapping Eminem
now Vincent America's Got Talent that's
what you were involved in you're
America's number one Eminem impersonator
how should he have done that better give
us a go
um I very close to it but you got to hit
that ah you gotta hit that because it
starts off with the whisper right but if
it starts to get mad it goes back to
slam stage two but then we start to get
really pissed off it starts to scream is
lose yourself in the music the moment
you want it you better never let it go
you only get one shot do not miss your
chance to blow this opportunity comes
once in a lifetime you better so that's
that's how I would very good very very
good you've got
you've got us convinced too